une paix sans conquête voilà ce qu'il
faut exiger 11 novembre à 11 heures les
cloches ont sonné les 100 ans de
l'armistice à versailles un peu avant
cinq associations célébrer la paix la
paix menacé tout le monde sent bien que
non seulement au niveau mondial mais au
niveau européen
disons que la guerre se rapproche on va
dire les choses comme ça et que les
conditions qui ont permis les guerres
dont nous avons parlé ce matin la guerre
de 14 ou la seconde guerre mondiale se
réunissent à nouveau et même si ça prend
des formes nouvelles
le lieu choisi le camp militaire de
versailles satory
des milliers de prisonniers y ont été
internés des communards ont été fusillés
en 1871
devant ce mur des fédérés sont des
hommes et des femmes qui se sont élevés
contre la guerre contre ces dictatures
militaires qui voulaient ce tour et je
mentais et donc on est dans la même
logique de guerre à la guerre nous avons
saisi l'occasion de l'armistice pour
effectivement va commémorer cet
événement et faire un appel pour la paix
nous pensons que la guerre aucune guerre
ni tindi luc table une bonne négociation
doit être réalisé à chaque fois qu'un
conflit
se fait jour elle les associations se
rassembleront à nouveau l'année
prochaine sauf si leur espoir devienne
réalité
que la paix soit établie